Tonight, we're going to talk about the
seven seals.
And then we're going to have another
talk on the seven trumpets.
And these are thunderous issues.
And we are slowly moving into a very
important phase when we will be opening
up some of the issues that will pertain
to our time
in a very, very special way.
Now,
I can only say it as it is.
And I pray that as we go through and
there are things which are strange or
you do not yet comprehend or do not even
wish to comprehend,
that you would not make this an issue
to stay away,
but to come and see more until the whole
picture
becomes clear. It's like a huge mosaic.
And all we can do in one evening is put
one little block
onto the screen.
And it looks like patchwork. And we
don't really understand the issues.
But if we can put one after the other
until the picture becomes clearer and
clearer and clearer,
then the whole import of the book of
Revelation
will start to
become intelligible.
So, bear with us and bear with me
if there are issues which seem strange
or perhaps skewed without all the other
information that is available.
Now, the seven seals are dealt with
mainly in chapter six.
But to set the stage for the seven
seals, there are two other chapters,
chapters four and five. And of course,
it is important to remember that the
chapters themselves say nothing because
the numbers in the Bible were added
afterwards. The Bible wasn't written
like that. The Bible was written as a
block.
So, you cannot really divide it up into
the numbers. The numbers are just
convenient for finding where you are
and
how to find a particular text.
The lamb opened one of the seals. Now,
before he opens the seals to tell us
what will happen on this earth,
he first gives us a view of the great
throne room in heaven. One of the most
picturesque views of the throne room of
the universe. Just imagine
having a look into that tremendous
seat of power. Revelation 4:1, "After
this I looked and behold a door was
opened in heaven, and the first voice
which I had heard was as it were of a
trumpet talking with me, which said,
'Come up hither,
and I will show you things which must be
hereafter.'" So, here you have the
prophetic view.
"And immediately I was taken in the
spirit and behold a throne was set in
heaven, and one sat
on the throne."
"But after thy hardness and impenitent
heart, treasurest up unto thyselves
wrath against the day of wrath and
revelation of the righteous judgments of
God in the day when God shall judge the
secrets of men by Jesus Christ according
to my gospel." Romans 2:5 and 16. What
has that got to do with the great throne
room?
Well, the great throne room is the seat
of the king of the universe.
And that king of the universe is also
the judge of the universe.
So, before God permits us to look into
what is going to happen on this earth
and to look at the apostasies that will
come and the terrible things that men
will do,
he gives us a view of his majesty and
his power.
And he gives us the view that in spite
of the fact that it looks as if the
other side is winning,
he's in control.
And finally, he will be the judge and
there will come a judgment. So, there
will be a judgment, an investigation,
a pronouncement of judgment, and then
will come an executive judgment.
And
when that executive judgment comes,
we better be on the right side.
"For we must all appear before the
judgment seat of Christ that everyone
may receive the things done in his
body." 2 Corinthians 5:10.
Make no mistake, Jesus is in control.
God is in control. Acts 17:31, "Because
he has appointed a day in which he will
judge the world in righteousness by that
man whom he has ordained, whereof he has
given assurance unto all men in that he
has raised him from the dead." Make no
mistake, Jesus will one day put an end
to sin.
Revelation 4:3, "And he that sat
was to look upon like a jasper
and a sardine stone, and there was a
rainbow around about the throne in the
sight like unto an emerald." It is
inexplicable to explain the glory that
John sees here in the throne room of
God.
"And around about the throne were four
and 20 seats." 24 seats around the
throne.
"And upon the seats I saw four and 20
elders sitting
clothed in white raiment, and they had
on their heads crowns of gold." So, here
are 24 individuals sitting around the
throne of God.
"And out of the throne proceeded
lightnings and thunders and voices." He
cannot even explain the glory that he
sees. He just sees flashes of light.
And
the voice of God like thunder. And there
were seven lamps of fire burning before
the throne, which are the seven spirits
of God. Now, we explained this before.
God is one. There is one spirit. But the
seven represents the time periods as we
went through them. God is in control in
all ages, including the one we are
living in now.
Now, who are these 24 elders?
Now, in the earthly sanctuary,
there were also 24 elders and we read
about it in the book of Chronicles
chapter 24:7.
And it tells us the lot fell and came
forth to Jehoiarib and second to
Jedaiah. And then it goes through them
all, the third and the fourth and the
fifth and the sixth and the seventh. And
it tells us who these elders were that
were chosen. And it details every single
one right through down to verse 19.
And 23, 24 elders. "These were the
orderings of them in their service to
come into the house of the Lord
according to their manner
under Aaron their father
as the Lord God of Israel had commanded
him." So, in the earthly sanctuary,
there were 24 elders that officiated
with the high priest, who was Aaron.
So, if the earthly was a type of the
heavenly, then in the heavenly there are
24 elders who officiate with the high
priest, who is Jesus,
in the heavenly sanctuary. It would be
interesting to know who they are,
but of course, we are not told who they
are.
But we can speculate some.
Revelation 4:6, "And before the throne
there was a sea of glass." He just sees
this magnificent light that you could
walk on
"like unto crystals, and in the midst of
the throne and around about the throne
were four beasts
full of eyes before and behind." Now,
who are they?
"And the first beast was like a lion,
and the second like a calf,
and the third beast had the face of a
man.
And the fourth beast like a flying
eagle. And the four beasts had each of
them six wings about him and they were
full of eyes within. And they rest not
day and night saying, "Holy, holy, holy
Lord God almighty which was and is and
is to come."
Interesting statement.
So, who are they?
Well, in Isaiah chapter 6 verse 2, we
have another statement that can help us.
It says, "Above it stood the seraphims."
Each one had six wings.
With twain, with two, he covered his
face. And with twain, two, he covered
his feet. And with twain, he did fly.
So, we're talking about cherubims. These
are an order of angelic beings.
They were so magnificent and so imposing
and they looked so powerful that John
describes them as beasts. And he gives
them the attributes of the lion and the
calf and the man and the flying eagle.
But you can see with what reverence they
stand before God. Gives you an an idea
of the holiness of God. Now, who
do they represent? Well, the traditional
view
is that the lion stands for
strength.
The calf stands for endurance, the man
for intelligence, and the flying eagle
for swiftness. So, they can see all
things around them. They are aware of
all things. And they are the ones
closest to God.
Covering cherubs, if you like.
Another view is that they reflect the
attributes of Christ.
You see, the lion is a symbol of a king.
And Jesus is the king.
The calf
or the heifer
is the one that serves, that pulls the
plow, if you like.
And so, it is a symbol of Christ the
servant. The man,
he has the appearance of a man. Christ
became man for us. So, it represents his
humanity.
And the flying eagle in the scriptures
is used as a symbol of divinity.
Jesus says, "I will lift you up as an
eagle.
Under the wings you will be." So, it's a
symbol of divinity. It's interesting
that the occult world uses these four
symbols also for its deity.
So, if Satan was a covering cherub and
he is now a fallen angel,
then he wanted to be like the most high.
Then it's interesting that these are the
attributes which he claims for himself
as well.
So, you see, if you see symbols,
sometimes we
freak about all the symbols, but many of
them are actually drawn from the
scriptures and Satan is counterfeiting
them to his own purposes.
But in the throne room of God, you see
the lamb of God. He is king. He is
servant. He is human. He became man for
us. But he is divine. That would be the
symbolism.
And when those beasts give glory and
honor and thanks to him that sat on the
throne who liveth forever and ever, the
four and 20 elders fall down before him
that sat on the throne and worship him.
Very interesting.
That liveth forever and ever and cast
their
crowns before the throne saying, "Thou
art worthy, oh Lord, to receive glory
and honor and power, for thou has
created all things.
And for thy pleasure they are and were
created." Now, the Bible is very clear
as to who the creator is.
All things were created
by
the word of Jesus Christ, says the
Bible. But we will deal with that in
another lecture.
And I saw in the right hand of him that
sat on the throne a book written within
and on the backside sealed with seven
seals. Chapter 5 verse 1.
And I saw a strong angel proclaiming
with a loud voice, "Who is worthy to
open the book and to loose the seals
thereof?"
And no man in heaven,
so there are some people in heaven,
nor in the earth,
neither under the earth, so none of the
dead either would have qualified, no
matter how good they were, whether they
were Abrahams or whether they were
King Davids or whether they were Adam
himself, none of them qualified, was
open able to open the book neither to
look thereat.
So, who were these
people that he saw in heaven? Now, the
cherubs we can understand. They were
angels. But the 24 elders?
Well, the Bible says that when Jesus
rose from the dead,
the graves were opened. Isn't that
right?
And the firstfruits rose from the dead.
And the Bible says when he entered into
heaven, when he ascended into heaven, he
took captives in his train. Isn't that
right?
So, people that had been redeemed
throughout the ages were raised from the
dead at that stage and went with him to
heaven.
The Bible also tells us that there are
some other individuals in heaven. Enoch,
for example, was translated without
seeing death and was taken up into
heaven. Isn't that right?
Elijah, as a representative of those who
will be translated
after the flood, was also taken up by
the chariots of God into heaven. Isn't
that right? So, Elijah is there.
And then there's an interesting verse in
in
Jude
where Michael argues with Satan over the
body of Moses.
So, Moses had a special resurrection and
was taken up into heaven. And that is
why Elijah and Moses could appear on the
Mount of Transfiguration
and support Christ in the time of his
agony before he went through the
episodes that confronted him in his
final hours. So, there are a number of
individuals in heaven.
And of those, obviously, there are 24
that serve in the heavenly
sanctuary as the 24 elders. Who exactly?
We do not know. We could speculate that
Moses might be one of them or that um
Elijah and Enoch. But the other names,
we just don't have them. We'll see one
day. We'll find out who they were.
But the interesting story. So, the
earthly a type of the heavenly.
But no man was worthy to open the seals.
Whether he was worthy enough in the eyes
of God to have been taken up into heaven
made no difference. Because no man in
heaven and no man on earth and no man
under the earth that had ever lived
would have been worthy to open the
seals. But fortunately,
there is a solution.
Revelation 5 verse 4, "And I wept much
because no man was found worthy to open
and to read the book neither to look
thereat."
Now, this document was sealed with seven
seals. In the old days, they used to
seal in Roman times a testament, a last
will and testament with seven seals.
And of course, if that is not opened,
then there is no inheritance.
So, if the seven sealed book is not
opened, there is no inheritance and we
are forever lost. That is why he wept.
But if they could be opened and the will
be read and there be an execution of the
will,
then
we could be redeemed.
And there is only one
who left a will and testament and lives
in order to receive it. Because
normally, when you die and you leave a
will and testament,
you have to depend on someone else to
open it. Isn't that right?
And to execute it.
And if the only one who can inherit it
is the one who died, well, then you have
a problem because the one who's dead is
dead and can't inherit it anymore.
Unless, of course,
he is God and has been resurrected
through his own power. Wow.
And so, we find
that one of the elders said unto me,
"Weep not. Behold, the lion of the tribe
of Judah, the root of David has
prevailed to open the book and to loose
the seven seals thereof."
So, all is not lost.
The God-man is there.
And I beheld and lo, in the midst of the
throne.
So, what does that make him?
If he is in the midst of the throne,
well, then he is sitting
in the seat of deity.
And of the four beasts and in the midst
of the elders stood a lamb
as it had been slain, having seven
horns, horn the seat of power,
kingship over all the ages. He is a
king. If you look in the book of Daniel,
you'll see that a horn stands for a king
or a kingdom.
And seven eyes, he sees throughout the
ages, which are the seven spirits of God
sent forth into all the earth, not part
of it.
Verse seven, and he came and took the
book out of the right hand of him that
sat upon the throne. And when he had
taken the book, the four beasts and the
four and 20 elders fell down before the
lamb,
having every one of them harps and
golden vials full of odors, which are
the prayers of the saints.
So, the prayers of the saints are
represented as incense.
And the merits of Christ make the
prayers acceptable to God.
Wonderful imagery that we have here. And
heavenly music fills the throne room as
they worship the lamb. And they sung a
new song, saying, "Thou art worthy to
take the book and to open the seals
thereof, for thou was" And here is the
answer, "slain
and has redeemed us
to God by thy blood." So, these four and
20 elders that are saying this, were
they humans or were they angels?
They must have been humans. Why?
Because they were redeemed. That's
right. So, we know that there are humans
in heaven right now
who were redeemed. And the ones that are
in heaven are those that went up in the
firstfruits, as we said. And the three
that we know of, that the Bible
mentions, that were translated or had a
special resurrection.
"For thou was slain and has redeemed us
to God by thy blood out of every kindred
and tongue and people and nation." That
gets rid of all exclusivity.
So, there are some that believe today
that salvation is by birth. Have you
noticed that there are people like that?
People who believe in salvation by
birth.
They say, "I belong to the right race,
or I belong to the right ethnic group,
therefore I am saved."
The Jews had that particular theology.
And there are many groups in the world
today that they who believe that they
are saved as a consequence of their
particular stature.
There are many interesting beliefs out
there. Salvation by name,
salvation by hat.
But I won't get into that. Some people
believe that if you have the right
dress,
then you are redeemed. And they
represent them likes themselves like
that to the world. You're not saved by
your birth. You're not saved by what you
wear or how you conform to this, that,
or the other position. You are saved
through your relationship with Jesus
Christ. That is how you are saved.
So, he's the one that redeems us by his
blood out of every kindred, tongue, and
people, and nation, lest we should boast
that one is better than another.
And has made us unto our God kings and
priests. And we shall reign on the
earth. Fascinating text. We shall reign
on the earth. And I beheld and I heard
the voice of many angels around about
the throne and the beasts and the
elders, and the number of them was
10,000 * 10,000 and thousands of
thousands. So, we're dealing with
billions here. Saying with a loud voice,
"Worthy is the lamb that was slain to
receive power and riches and wisdom and
strength and honor and glory and
blessing." So, you have this tremendous
view of the scene in heaven,
showing that the final victor is going
to be who?
Jesus Christ.
So, we have nothing to fear.
It's interesting that God gives us this
view,
and then he shifts the emphasis
to tell us what's going to happen on
this earth. And the two are in such
contrast with each other that it's
scary.
Scary. And one might believe that
Christianity
is the loser on this issue.
Did you know that the greatest apparent
victory for Satan
was his greatest defeat.
When he had Jesus nailed to that cross,
and he was triumphing in his power and
glory,
he actually sounded his death knell.
And so it will be with the whole
Christian church. The greatest apparent
defeat will be turned by the merits of
Jesus Christ into the greatest victory
that the universe has ever seen. Make no
mistake. Jesus is in control.
And when we go through the next
lectures, remember those words, because
there are going to be some scary things
we are going to talk about. But we can
whistle and smile and sing hymns,
because we know the outcome already.
"And every creature which is in heaven
and on earth and under the earth and
such as though are in the sea" That's
symbol of the nations. "And all that are
in them heard I saying, 'Blessing and
honor and glory and power be unto him
that sitteth upon the throne and unto
the lamb forever and ever.'" It'll be a
universal eternal kingdom.
"And the four beasts, the cherubs, said,
'Amen.'" And the four and 20 elders, who
had been redeemed, remember, fell down
and "worshipped him that liveth forever
and ever."
Right. Having shifted from the great
throne room scene, we move to the story
of the horses of Revelation, the opening
of the seals.
The lamb opened one of the seals,
Revelation 6:1.
And he sees a horse, a rider on a white
horse, come forth conquering.
Now, again, we are going to go through
seven time periods.
Now, the sign time periods obviously
recapitulate what we saw before when we
dealt with the seven churches, because
the seven churches tell us about the
nature of God's church. With all its
defects, God doesn't hide anything. And
he tells us, "This is what's going to
happen to the church."
Now, these horses represent something
else.
They're going to recapitulate the same
time periods, but they're going to
concentrate on the message, on the
gospel herald. So, not so much the
position of the church that is to herald
the information, but the actual message
that has to go out to the world. And
Satan, of course, is as opposed to that
message as he was to the Son of God. He
hates it with a passion.
So, when this horse goes out white, what
is the color white? What does it
represent?
Righteousness.
The Bible tells us it represents
righteousness. And there is nobody
righteous but
Christ.
And he has a bow in his hand.
So, there are a number of symbols that
we can look at. And then there is a
another rider, one with a red horse.
Then there is a black one, and then
there is a dead one, with a dead rider.
So, who are these riders? Revelation
6:1-2. "And I saw when the lamb opened
one of the seals, and behold a white
horse. And he that sat on him had a bow"
There's a clue.
"and a crown" There's another clue. "and
was given unto him.
And he went forth conquering and to
conquer."
So, there's a war here. There's a war.
You go out to conquer in a war
situation.
Psalm 64:7 will give us a clue. "But God
shall shoot at them with an arrow."
Who shall shoot?
God. "Suddenly shall they be wounded."
So, who's the one who has the bow?
It's God.
"Was the Lord displeased against the
rivers?
Was thine anger against the rivers? Was
thy wrath against the sea, and that thou
didst ride upon thine horses and thy
chariots of salvation?
Thy bow" There we have the clue. "was
made quite naked, according to the oaths
of the tribes, even thy word. Selah.
Thou didst cleave the earth with
rivers." Habakkuk chapter 3:8-9. Now,
here we have a nice clue.
Is God concerned with conquering the
planet in terms of earthly thinking? No.
This is a message. It's the word of God,
and the arrow is the one that shoots and
brings the gospel into the heart. And
the first message that went out when
Jesus started his fledgling church was
the message of salvation through Jesus
Christ, and it went out with power and
purity
because God had cleansed for himself a
people that were willing to stand for
righteousness and truth. The early
church. So,
the gospel herald that went out
was unadulterated.
Everybody knew
that Jesus Christ was Lord. He alone was
able to save
and that through his blood we are
redeemed. That is the story that went
out into the world to bring the gospel
heralds. So, it's a conquering faith.
White represents a pure faith.
A white woman, the woman dressed in
white in Revelation, represents
truth in its purity. The bride that has
been redeemed and washed in the blood of
the lamb.
If you continue in the faith grounded
and settled and be not moved away from
the hope of the gospel which you have
heard
and which was preached to every creature
which is under heaven. Colossians 1:23.
23.
It's very important.
If you accept this message
and you are anchored on the rock so that
you cannot be moved,
then you are settled in the truth.
And in order to be settled in the truth
so that you cannot be moved, you have to
know the word of God and you have to eat
it.
That means to internalize it and to act
accordingly. And we will see that to be
so settled in the truth that you cannot
be moved is a very important point that
we'll be dealing with in a moment.
So, the second seal is opened
and here comes
a red horse. Red is the color of what?
Sacrifice. It's the color of blood. It's
the color of sacrifice. So, when we
looked at the seven churches, the first
one was Ephesus. Do you remember?
And it was a church that had a good
message and it was a pure doctrine and
they had discernment. They could see who
those were that called themselves Jews,
Christians, and were not and who tried
to infiltrate even at that early stage,
but discernment kept them out.
And then came
another church that was called Smyrna.
Do you remember that? Myrrh. And what
happened there?
There was a time of great
persecution and the blood flowed. So,
here
blood is flowing
and the reason why this blood is flowing
is because Satan is counteracting the
gospel message and he's doing everything
in his power to corrupt it.
Those true to principle would rather die
than give it up and those not true to
principle, what would they do?
They would start compromising.
And so, the road to compromise
was slowly opened.
And the red gospel horse went out. And
there went out another horse that was
red and power was given to him that sat
there on to take peace from the earth.
And that they should kill one another
and there was given unto him a great
sword. Now, what is the sword?
The word of
God. So, that's the issue. The word of
God. Out it goes. It says one thing.
This brings about war.
And war is painful.
War leads to death and some people get
tired of the process. So, a bloodstained
faith is the next one.
It's a time of great persecution, Roman
persecution
with Nero and all the issues we dealt
with
when we dealt with the churches. So, it
covers the same time period up to the
time of Constantine when persecution
was the method method to get rid of the
gospel herald.
And when he had opened the third seal, I
heard the third beast say, "Come and
see."
And I beheld and lo, a black horse.
And he that sat on him had a pair of
balances in his hand.
And I heard a voice in the midst of the
four beasts
say,
"A measure of wheat for a penny
and three measures of barley for a penny
and see that they are hurt not the oil
and the wine." These are interesting
symbols. So, here is a balance
and the color is
black.
Now, black is obviously the opposite of
white. Isn't that right?
So, something is happening to taint the
whiteness of the pure gospel herald. It
becomes black. And there's something
that becomes very scarce.
Wheat and barley.
And then there is something else that is
in trouble.
Wine
and oil. Now, these symbols stand all of
them stand for the gospel herald.
You see, the wheat is a symbol of Jesus
Christ. Jesus Christ was born in
Bethlehem, Bethlehem,
the bread basket. Jesus says, "I am the
bread of life."
Jesus is the living bread that comes
down from heaven.
So, the bread
is in trouble.
And the barley was the first harvest
that took place in Israel, the barley
harvest. In fact, the wave offering was
from barley sheaves. And it represents
also
the resurrection in Jesus Christ and the
body of Christ, the herald. So, the
wheat and the barley will become scarce.
The gospel message of salvation in
Christ is under pressure. But God is
still working and he says, "Do not harm
the oil and the wine." What does the oil
stand for?
It's the symbol of the Holy Spirit. It
was poured into the candlesticks so that
the world might have the light of truth.
And wine is a symbol of doctrine.
Jesus says, "You cannot pour new wine
into old wineskins.
You cannot pour the great message of
salvation in Christ into a mold
that will not contain it." So, the wine
is a symbol of the gospel. Jesus also
says, "I am the vine, you are the
branches." He is the one that gives us
life through his gospel herald.
So, these are the issues that are being
put under pressure, compromised if you
like.
So, the black horse obviously represents
a time
when the word of God becomes scarce.
And this is when the compromise issue
comes in. So, this is the time when
Constantine
married paganism to Christianity. So,
it's a compromised faith if we follow
the same time periods.
Take heed therefore unto yourselves and
to all the flock
to feed the church of God for I know
this
that after my departing shall grievous
wolves enter in amongst you.
So, by the way,
how early in the church would corrupting
influences come in?
Right in the beginning.
There was a man called Simon Magus. Do
you remember him? In the Bible?
And he thought he could buy the power of
God with his money. Do you remember
that?
And Peter rebuked him to his face.
And he was upset about it. He was very
upset about it.
And Simon Magus
was from Sumeria.
And he had a taint of Babylonian wisdom.
And if we go into the history as we see
in the future, he was probably the
father of Gnosticism.
And Gnosticism
is the issue where Christ is made less
than he is so that we can become greater
than we are, in a nutshell.
And Gnosticism
was the
thorn in the flesh of early Christianity
and Gnosticism
is the controlling factor today as we
will see in future lectures.
The cross of Christ
was the divide of history.
But it cast down the truth to the ground
and it practiced and it prospered.
Daniel 8:12. There would come a power
that would
destroy the gospel herald.
Salvation through Christ alone was
replaced by the requirements of the
church. So, that's basically
what happened.
And the church set itself up as the
mediator between man and God. Instead of
going directly to Christ, you went
through the church. A very sad day. God
had given a law
and man had the effrontery to change the
law of God to
suit his own needs.
So, in the churches we have St. Peter or
was it Jupiter?
Well, actually it came straight out of a
temple of Jupiter.
In the churches, Mary became
a mediatrix,
a mediator.
And the church teaches
that nobody can be saved except through
the merits of Mary.
That's very strange.
So, all these issues came in and they
were a mingling of paganism and
Christianity.
The Bible says quite clearly there is no
other name under heaven and earth
whereby you may be saved except the name
of Christ
Jesus. There is no other name.
So, all these other mediators started
coming in and where the pagans had many
many many gods,
so they just developed many many many
many saints.
And then you could, if you had a problem
in your life
and you came short
on merits,
salvation by works, in order to enter
into heaven, well, then you could borrow
from the excess of merit of those who
had gone before you. This is
doctrine of the church of the Middle
Ages and it is doctrine today.
And so, you could borrow, if you like,
take for yourself a deep spoon of the
merit of the saints that had gone before
to augment the paucity of your own
merits.
Is that biblical?
Or does each one stand before God in the
judgment
and gives an account for what he has
done in the flesh, yes or no?
Yes, of course.
And so, all these saints were created
and then eventually the saints became
specialized and that specialization is
exactly the same as it you had in
paganism. One god was
specialist in taking care of you during
traveling.
Another one was a specialist in taking
care of your financial needs and so, you
had various gods. And so, today, if you
want to travel, well, it's good to have
a St. Christopher around
because that might just, you know, help
you in your travels.
So,
this is a church of compromise.
And with Jesus Christ,
there can be no compromise. Either he is
Lord of lords and King of kings
or he is not.
And that is the choice that we have to
make.
As we go into the next part of the story
of the riders of the Apocalypse,
we come to a pale horse, one that
represents death. So, obviously there's
a shift in this time when the gospel
herald became black,
darkened through compromise to a point
of death.
The gospel has died.
The Bible says quite clearly, "Thou
shalt not make unto thee any graven
image or any likeness of anything that
is in heaven above or that is in the
earth beneath or that is in the water
under the sea. Thou shalt not bow down
thyself to them nor serve them." Exodus
20:4-5.
Problematic text in the Ten
Commandments. So, how about just
removing it?
Throwing it into the dustbin.
Well, if you look at a normal catechism
book today,
you will find that this commandment has
been removed to open the way for the
practices that went before.
Constantine is the one who first and
foremost started to make legislation
that would bind the conscience of human
beings. So, rather than listening and
accepting the word of God and making
your decisions based on the word of God,
man started legislating
on this issue. And Constantine was the
first one to legislate a day of rest,
for example. During this age of
compromise,
the pagan's day of the sun replaced the
Bible Sabbath. Very interesting
development that happened over there.
The early church kept the Sabbath.
There were two regions where the Sabbath
was not kept in the early church. The
one was in Alexandria
where you had the very liberal school
which later became the seat of
Gnosticism
and the other one was in Rome.
And those two areas were the bastion
of
sun worship. It's interesting that when
Alexandria was destroyed, the shift of
power moved towards Rome and eventually
spread across the entire world.
So, during this age of compromise, the
day of the sun replaced the Bible
Sabbath. We are told by Eusebius, by the
way, that is the bishop that was active
in Constantine's time, that Constantine,
in order to recommend the new religion
to the heathen, transferred into it the
outward ornaments to which they had been
accustomed in their own.
Development of the Christian doctrine,
page 372. So, this is what they started
doing. They started compromising on
these issues.
Arthur P. Stanley says, "Constantine's
coins bore on the one side the letters
of the name of Christ and on the other
the figure of the sun god
as if he could not dare to relinquish
the patronage of the bright luminary."
Interesting name, luminary. Today, we
also have people who consider themselves
luminaries,
illuminated ones. There's even an
organization which calls itself the
Illuminati.
We'll be dealing with those issues as we
go along. So, here is a
compromise that has taken place. The
retention of the old pagan name of Deus
Solus or Sunday isn't a great measure
owing to the union of pagan and
Christian sentiment with which the first
day of the week was recommended by
Constantine to his subjects, pagan and
Christian alike, as the venerable day of
the sun. History of the Eastern Church,
page 184. So, this is historic fact. We
cannot deny it. This is what happened.
"For in six days," says the Bible, "the
Lord made the heavens, the earth, the
sea and all that in them is." Wow, is
that sentence under attack today in the
scientific world, yes or no?
Like you cannot believe.
There is hardly a word in the word of
God that is not being assailed in this
day and age that we live in.
"All that in them is and he rested the
seventh day, wherefore the Lord blessed
the Sabbath day and he hallowed it."
Exodus 20:11.
So, here were issues of compromise that
were coming in
and they were changing the face of
Christianity.
Now, what about all those
dear Christians
that wanted to do exactly what the
scriptures said?
What happened to them?
They were eliminated
off the face of the earth.
They were destroyed
by sword.
And the story of how it was done is the
most diabolical, scariest story that we
can imagine in the world today.
Wow. Where did the early church reign?
Where did Christianity start? Did it
start in Rome, yes or no?
No.
Started in Jerusalem.
That's where it started. That's where
Christianity has it its seat.
And it spread across the Middle East.
Where did Paul do most of his preaching?
He went to Rome to die, but where did he
establish the churches?
In Asia Minor.
That's where he preached and that's
where the church grew.
And the church grew across the
entire region which is today Iraq and
Iran and Pakistan, all the way up to
India. That's what the Bible says.
And into Egypt and into the north of
Africa. That's where the cradle of
Christianity was.
And today,
Christianity has been obliterated
from its seat of origin and has been
replaced by an entirely different
religion
which denies
Christ
and his divinity. Interesting thought.
We'll come to that in a moment.
"And God blessed the seventh day and he
sanctified it because that in it he
rested from all the work which God
created and made.
The Catholic Encyclopedia
tells us the church after changing the
day of rest from the Jewish Sabbath or
seventh day of the week to the first,
made the third commandment refer to
Sunday as the day
to be kept holy as the Lord's day. The
Catholic Encyclopedia volume 4 page 153.
Well, why the third commandment? Why not
the fourth like it was in the Bible?
Because they had removed the second
commandment which says, "Thou shalt not
make for yourself an idol." Now, is that
not messing with the word of God?
Isn't that rewriting the scriptures?
Absolutely.
So, not only did they take the authority
of God away who said, "Remember the
seventh day because I am your creator
and I made you."
They took it away and said, "No, I will
decide when you shall do what and I am
the new authority in your life." So,
it's not a question of a day as much as
it is a question of authority.
Who has authority?
The one who makes the law is the one who
has the authority. The one who changes
the law is the one who says he has more
authority than the one that went before,
right or wrong?
So, here is a power that says, "I have
more authority than God. I'll change
it."
It's a question of authority. Don't mess
with God.
Her priests have violated my law and
have profaned mine holy things. They
have put no difference between the holy
and the profane.
Neither have they showed difference
between the unclean and the clean.
And have hid their eyes from my Sabbath
and I'm profaned amongst them. Ezekiel
22:26.
That's an interesting statement.
So, they profane the Sabbaths. They make
no difference between clean and unclean.
Hang on a second.
Aren't we taught today that there is a
difference? That there is no difference
anymore. Isn't that right?
I mean, if you read the NIV, it even
says there, "Thereby
Jesus declared that all things are now
clean."
So, the NIV says. King James doesn't say
it, but the NIV says it. Very
interesting.
We'll have to look into that issue. It's
a bit complicated now. It's just sort of
to wet your appetites.
So, the black horse represented this
time of compromise when things started
to change and by 538 AD, a decree went
out that a certain power, the bishop of
Rome, had the power to become the
corrector of heretics.
That means he became the authority
to dictate the conscience of men.
Interesting.
Not God.
Man had taken that position.
And once man usurps the authority of
God, then the gospel is
dead.
Because my Bible says there is no other
name whereby you can be saved. And my
Bible says there is no other mediator
except the man Christ Jesus. And my
Bible also says that if somebody sins,
we have an advocate.
And that advocate is Jesus Christ. But
now we have another advocate. We have to
go elsewhere to find forgiveness. And we
have someone who tells us what's right
and what's wrong contrary to what the
word of God said. This is problematic.
This is problematic.
And when he had opened the fourth seal,
I looked and behold a pale horse. And
his name that sat on him was death.
And hell followed with him. Hades, the
grave.
This is a sad story of how a gospel
message of salvation was
taken to the point of death.
And power was given unto them over the
fourth part of the earth.
So, this power
that takes away the gospel herald
controlled a fourth part of the earth.
Well, that's an interesting point.
Which Christian denomination controlled
the fourth part of the world? Wow. To
kill with a sword.
That's a new word. And a literal sword.
And with hunger. Hunger for what?
There's a famine in the land for what?
For the word of God.
Did the church of the Middle Ages take
the word of God away, yes or no?
Did it ban the Bible? Was it a sin to
the point of death to have and read the
Bible, yes or no? Yes, history proves
the fact. I'm not attacking any
individual. I'm talking about a system.
And what is behind the system? There are
many, many, many dear people hungering
for truth in every single religion in
the world. And I believe many of them
God recognizes as his own because they
are living up to the best light that
they have.
So, let's not be judgemental. We're
talking about a system.
And uh
it's a sad, sad system.
My father wanted to be a Roman Catholic
priest. He was very, very good Catholic.
I was raised Roman Catholic.
And uh
I became an atheist.
But I became a Catholic again.
And when I discovered the Bible,
I saw that there were so many issues
that were not biblical.
And I had to make a choice. And I have
to believe everybody has to come to that
point where he has to make a choice
between
being fooled by the systems of man or by
the systems of God.
And with death
and with the beasts of the earth. So,
how did he kill? He killed with a sword.
That's literal that he made. He killed
with a famine for the word of God. And
he killed with a death and with beasts.
Beast in Daniel is a kingdom.
The four beasts you saw are four
kingdoms that shall arise upon the
earth. Daniel chapter 7.
So, he killed with political powers. Did
the church of the Middle Ages do that,
yes or no?
Absolutely. Take the Waldenses. The
Waldenses were destroyed off the face of
the earth. The Albigenses, France.
The first alliance between a European
nation and Rome was with the Franks.
Clovis
became a champion emperor for the cause.
And any opposition was destroyed.
And the gospel died.
Man had taken the position of God.
So, the new Christians were as far as
thinking and habits went the same as the
old pagans.
Their surge into the churches did not
wipe out paganism. On the contrary,
hordes of baptized pagans meant that
paganism had diluted the moral energies
of organized Christianity to the point
of impotence. Centuries of Christianity,
a concise history page 58. History
attests to the facts. And unfortunately,
I cannot change them. I didn't invent
them.
I'm just telling you what the book of
Revelation says about these issues.
The faith had died.
And formalism took the place of a
simple, beautiful trust in the son of
God.
Do you know
when I was a Catholic,
I used to sit in the church
and I used to know that according to the
teaching, the host was in the tabernacle
and that was God and I could pray to
him.
I used to sit there and I used to say,
"Why don't you answer me?
Why can I not bring my problems to you
and speak to you as to a friend?"
Everything is ritual. If you want to
communicate with God,
say 10 Hail Marys, one Our Father, 10
Hail Marys, one Our Father, 10 Hail
Marys, one Our Father and pray right
through the rosary
and end up
with the confession of faith.
If you haven't got it done yet, do it
again.
And again. And again. And the more you
do it,
the better.
Is that communicating with someone?
Is that how you would speak to someone
you love?
You know, man has a hunger
to communicate with God.
Man has a hunger
to touch and feel
the divine hand.
And man is being robbed of the beauty
and the simplicity of communication with
God.
Prayer
is not bringing God down to us. Prayer
is bringing us up to God. Isn't that a
beautiful sense of upliftment?
We are left down here with all the
problems of the world with no solution
when God is just a prayer away.
If we would say, "Lord, I have a
problem.
Can I come to you?"
I'm sure the Lord will incline his ear
to us
and will listen to every word that
troubles us. We can take our largest
problems and our smallest problems
directly to God.
We need no one else.
It is a beautiful truth.
And when we discover it, then no matter
how glorious and pompous and beautiful
everything is,
without love, there is nothing.
What does What does Solomon say? Rather
live on the corner of the roof
and rather have a house with cabbage
leaves than a house filled with good
food if there is no love.
It's no point in it.
Rather be poor and have love than to
have riches and sadness.
There's nothing wrong with being rich.
God can bless riches as well. It's the
love of money that is the root of all
evil. If you leave the love of out, then
you have a problem.
So, a union of church and state came
about.
Governments were used to enforce
doctrine. Christianity became an
established religion in the Roman Empire
and took the place of paganism.
Christianity as it existed in the Dark
Ages might be termed baptized paganism.
Church history, century
2, chapter 2, section 7. These are
statements made by the church
themselves.
They even said the God Pan is not dead,
he is baptized.
So, paganism rules in the world today.
And there is an elevation
of the priesthood over man.
That is the most diabolical thing that
has ever happened in the history of the
human race. Did you know that?
To elevate one portion to control the
conscience of others. And we have the
same problem today.
There are some who believe that because
they have theology,
they have the right to control your
conscience. Hello?
Each one is accountable to God himself.
And the Bible teaches no such thing
unless you change the Bible.
We'll be dealing with that.
It's been changed somewhere. Not in the
old ones, they're still fine. You can
read the old German Luther Bible, that's
great. You can read the Armenian Bible,
that's great. You can read any Bible
from Russia to Serbia, anywhere in the
world, you'll find it all nice and right
there.
But there's a problem later on where you
have an elevation of the priesthood over
the general people. There's no such
thing in the Bible.
But the path of the just is as the
shining light that shineth more and more
unto the perfect day. Proverbs 4:18.
So, the light of truth would penetrate
into this darkness. God would not permit
his gospel to die.
So, God had to do something. What was
the next church that was to bring light
and the word back to the people?
Remember the seven churches?
We had the church that came in,
Sardis,
and it represented the reformation
to reform that which had died. It's
really not a complicated concept.
And when he had opened the fifth seal, I
saw under the altar the souls of them
that were slain for the word of God and
for the testimony which they held. And
they cried with a loud voice saying,
"How long, oh Lord, holy and true, dost
thou not judge and avenge our blood on
them that dwell on the earth?"
Now, are these literal souls under the
altar? It must be pretty crowded there.
Or is this the blood of all the saints
crying out to God, "When are you going
to do something about this?" Think
that's the image that we're getting
here. So, all those that died for the
faith,
all those that were destroyed for what
they believed, crying out to God.
And white robes were given unto every
one of them, and it was said unto them
that they should rest, sleep, yet a
little season until their fellow
servants also and their brethren that
should be killed as they were should be
fulfilled. God says,
"I'm in control. It's going to get
worse.
But wait till everybody throughout
history that is still going to die in
the faith or for the faith
is together, and then the kingdom will
come."
So, these are instruments of torture
that were used. Nothing could stop the
gospel herald.
And uh Did you know that some of these
instruments of torture were still used
in 1974?
Very interesting. Franco in Fra- uh in
Spain
used those instruments of torture still
in the 1970s.
Beloved, when I gave all diligence to
write unto you of the common salvation,
it was needful for me to write unto you
and to exhort you that you should
earnestly contend for the faith which
was once delivered unto the saints.
Don't just give up.
For there are certain men crept in
unawares, ungodly men turning the grace
of our God into
lasciviousness and denying the only Lord
God and our Lord Jesus Christ. Jude
chapter
verse 3 and 4.
Wow.
So, right there in the early church, the
corruption came in. And what did they
deny?
Jesus Christ.
The only Lord God and our Lord Jesus
Christ. So, a shift took place in that
early church already. Big problem.
And we will see what they did because we
will go into it in detail and how it
affects us today because these smart
people
have done the same thing to us.
And we are not even aware of it. Isn't
that sad?
So, God wants us to know
like the successive strata of the earth
covering one another, so layer after
layer of forgeries, fabrications was
piled up in the church. The Pope and the
Councils, page 117.
Not only false doctrines elevating man
above the deity,
but actually false manuscripts
corrupting the word of God as well.
But there were the Waldenses. And where
did they get their manuscripts?
They got them from the Syrian Church,
from the cradle of Christianity. They
didn't get them from Rome.
They had the scriptures as they came
down the ages. It's interesting that
those nations that came across the top
areas, they had these scriptures. But
there were other documents that were
being used in Alexandria
and in Rome. We'll deal with that in
another lecture. And these people made
the word of God their bastion, and they
preached it, and because of that, the
ire of the world was upon them. And they
were fought tooth and nail. They were
burned. They were smashed their infants'
heads against the rocks. They threw them
down the cliffs. But the gospel would
not die.
This is an old Waldensian church
and uh Bible copyist's table there.
And so slowly the faith was
uplifted again.
In 1370, the authority of the Bible was
declared with power by Wycliffe.
In 1400, obedience to God. Obey God
rather than man. And he died for his
faith.
Jan Hus. These are the men dressed in
white.
And then salvation by grace, Martin
Luther.
What a stalwart. Did he do everything
perfectly? Absolutely not.
But man, did he live up to the knowledge
that he had, didn't he? He's a champion
in my eyes, and so is Jan Hus and
Wycliffe. These are real champions.
Tyndale and all these people that gave
up their lives for this truth. Martin
Luther had the courage to go and say,
"This is what's wrong. We have to
correct it." And we saw, "Here I stand,
and I can do no other." 1521.
Then John Calvin came on. Man, did he
have confused ideas?
Predestination,
this, that, and the other, all kinds of
ideas. But man, did he live up to the
knowledge that he had and the light that
he had?
Freedom of conscience. In fact, the
entire American Constitution is based on
what Calvin wrote.
That man should be accountable to God
alone for what he decides. That's the
basis of the American Constitution.
That's Calvinism.
He had many things wrong, but boy, did
he bring out this point. Right down the
throat of those who opposed it.
And these people died, and there are
monuments in their honor today.
And then Williams came along in 1650 and
he discovered baptism by immersion.
Beautiful truths in the Bible.
Unfortunately, as we said last time, all
these faiths
decided they wouldn't go along with new
light because they worshipped at the
shrines of their founders.
That's not the problem of the founders,
that's the problem of the followers,
right or wrong?
So, the followers have more of a problem
than the founders because if they
discovered light, they should embrace
it. But, no,
they wouldn't. So, we have a fragmented
church today.
Go ye therefore and teach all nations,
teaching them to observe What does it
say there?
All things whatsoever I have commanded
you, and lo, I am with you always, even
unto the end of the world. Matthew 28:19
and 20. These are the issues that are
important. All things.
Not I will accept only what my founder
discovered. All things or nothing.
So, if you are looking for a church,
what would you do?
Wouldn't you look for a church that
embraces all the truths of all the
faiths, yes or no?
Wouldn't you look for one that in the
Bible does everything
according
to the doctrine at least according to
the Bible? Don't look at individuals,
individuals are not trustworthy. You
must look at the Bible
and what the official teaching is. And
if it is what the Bible says and the
Bible alone, then go along with it.
Shouldn't be too difficult.
Then came Wesley
and he lifted up Jesus Christ like he'd
never been lifted up in the world
before.
The Lordship of Jesus Christ. If the
Lord Jesus is not the center, the author
of the finisher of our faith, forget it.
Then it's not biblical.
So, what a great discovery of light.
And I beheld when he had opened the
sixth seal,
and lo, there was a great earthquake.
Interesting. So, we're now coming into
an interesting time period. The
Reformation had done its work.
The churches that followed after Sardis
were which ones? Do you remember?
Phila- -delphia.
And here there was an accumulation of
truth. But, before this event, something
was going to happen. Behold, when he had
opened the sixth seal, and lo, there was
a great earthquake and the sun became
black as sackcloth of hair and the moon
became as blood.
And the stars of heaven fell onto the
earth even as fig tree casteth her
untimely figs when she is shaken of a
mighty wind. Revelation 6:12 and 13.
These are celestial signs.
Did they take place?
Absolutely.
Mark says the same thing. Chapter 13:24.
In those days after that tribulation,
that tremendous persecution where God's
people were virtually wiped off the face
of the earth in the Middle Ages through
the Inquisition and the 50-year war and
the 100-year war and Bartholomew night
and the Huguenots were hounded,
then came light. And after that
tribulation, which ended
roughly 1798, and we'll come to that in
another time, another lecture, the sun
shall be darkened and the moon shall not
give her light.
Well, here's the history of where New
Hampshire because Christianity had fled
Bible-based Christianity had fled from
Europe and established itself in a
number of regions in the world.
In the
the New World, the United States of
America in particular,
in Southern Africa and in Australia.
That's where Christianity had fled.
Interesting story as to what's happening
in those regions of the world today. The
dark day of New England, so familiar to
old and young, came May 19, 1780.
Near 11:00 it began to grow dark as if
night were coming. Men ceased their
work, the lowing cattle came to the
barns, the bleating sheep huddled about
the fences, the wild birds screamed and
flew to their nests, the fowls went to
their roosts. At night it was so inky
dark that a person could not see his
hand when held up nor even a white sheet
of paper.
That's the history of where New
Hampshire, 1735 to 1888.
The Independent Chronicle of June 8,
1780 said, "During the whole time a
sickly melancholy gloom overcast the
face of nature."
And uh it goes on to say that
notwithstanding there was almost a full
moon, which by the way was like blood,
no object was discernible.
And there was an Egyptian darkness
impervious to the eyes.
The great memorable events, the
Connecticut legislature was in session
and they gave it up because of the
darkness. They sojourned. And Herschel,
the great astronomer, admits that the
dark day, May 19, 1780 is something that
astronomy cannot explain. There was no
eclipse, there was no reason,
scientifically speaking, for it, but
there it was, right on time.
And then November 13, 1833, this amazing
shower from heaven with 200,000 meteors
per hour. It was so light you could
read. And the interesting thing is they
came from a central point. Normally, if
you have shooting stars, they're all
over the place, but not here.
They came from a central point and
spread across the sky. Nobody had ever
seen something like this before.
And prior to these events, there was the
great Lisbon earthquake. So, the
sequence exactly like in the Bible.
And something new had to be discovered.
Well, William Miller was the one, 1782
to 1849,
who started rediscovering something else
in the Bible. And he discovered some of
the great prophecies. Unto 2,300 days,
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed.
And he calculated the days and
discovered the beautiful Messianic
prophecies of Jesus and of the cleansing
of the sanctuary. And he thought,
"Wow, does this mean Jesus is coming
again?" And he started to preach that
Jesus was going to come in 1844 because
he figured that the cleansing of the
sanctuary meant the cleansing of the
earth. But, of course, Jesus didn't come
in 1844.
So, in the 1840s, there were a group of
believers that called themselves
Adventists.
Now, these weren't Seventh-day
Adventists, these were Adventists,
people that believed in the soon coming
of Christ. And they came from every
single Christian denomination
in the areas. They were Baptists and
Methodists and Presbyterians, you name
it, they were there.
Over 200 ministers of the various
churches believed in these studies that
made prophecy come to life again. But,
of course, it didn't happen, but at
least what it did,
it opened up the hope for the second
coming.
And William Miller is the herald for the
reestablishment
of prophecy and the role of prophecy in
uh Christian history. So, all these
great truths coming back into
the Christian thinking. And then, of
course, a final restoration had to take
place embracing all the truths.
The law of God,
doctrines on death and hell and all
these things, how we should live, what
the parameters were that God required
from us. All of these things had to be
restored because surely God would not
end it without light shining upon his
people to open up all the truths that
had been lost. Truth had to be restored.
And then, Christ would come.
Jesus said, "If you love me,
keep my commandments." John 14:15.
He who says he loves me and keeps not my
commandments is a what?
A liar and the truth is not in him.
Haven't we got many groups today that
say that the commandments have been done
away with?
Yes or no?
Yes, they've been nailed to the cross.
Jesus says
that the law will never pass away.
Heaven and earth will pass away,
but not one jot or one tittle will be
removed from the law until all things
have been accomplished.
Surely, it is common sense to know that
if people would just keep the law of
God, we can throw away all our keys.
And all the young ladies and women could
walk safely in the darkest alleys of
this world without any fear if everybody
kept the law of God. Isn't that right?
So, the law of God is going to be an
issue at the end of time, especially
since a whole organization has had the
effrontery to change it.
Wow.
To say we are greater and more powerful
than God, we will modify his law.
In vain do they worship me teaching for
doctrines the commandments of men.
Matthew 15:9.
When man elevates himself to the
position of or above God,
then you know that it is time for God to
act.
Thou shalt be called the repairer of the
breach,
the restorer of paths to dwell in, if
thou turn away thy foot from the
Sabbath, from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day, and call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy of the Lord honorable,
there would be a restoring of the
breach, the gap in the wall that is
supposed to protect us from evil. The
law was not made to restrict us.
The law was made to protect us. Like a
loving father or mother would put their
arms around their children and make
rules to protect them. And the Sabbath
was to be called a delight, not a
burden.
The Jews had made the Sabbath a burden.
They had placed placed so many
restrictions upon it that it was a
misery to keep it. Who could be happy if
you weren't even allowed to walk a
couple of paces to go and meet those you
loved? Wow.
So, there had to be a restoration of the
spirit of the law and faith in the word
of God.
The revelation
by John tells us all these things as
they would unfold. And I saw another
angel fly in the midst of heaven having
the everlasting gospel to preach unto
them that dwell on the earth and to
every nation and kindred and tongue and
people, saying with a loud voice, "Fear
God and give glory to him,
for the hour of his judgment is come.
And worship him that made the heavens,
the earth, the sea, and the fountains of
water." Revelation 14:6 and 7. The
gospel, the everlasting gospel, had to
be restored.
You see, the Jews
relied on obedience to the law.
And they nailed Jesus to the cross.
And the Christians rely on the merits of
Jesus and nail the law to the cross.
Both of them are standing on one leg.
Isn't that right?
The law and the gospel, they go
together.
If you want to choose Jesus as your
savior,
you must be prepared to accept him as
your king.
Isn't that right?
And a king is a ruler. And a ruler, by
the very name, has rules. Right or
wrong?
Yes.
And what's so difficult about
loving Jesus enough to keep his
commandments? It's not so tough.
If I love my wife
with all my heart and with all my soul,
would I want another?
Absolutely not.
And if I think of the consequences
that it would cause, the pain and the
suffering, would it even be worth it?
I don't think so.
Same with God. If I love God with all my
heart and with all my soul,
would I want to serve another?
Why not? They're useless. They can't
save me. They can't do anything for me.
Even if I had a selfish motive, it would
be better to stay true to God. Yes or
no?
Yes.
So, the law makes sense.
So,
here is a message that says, "God is the
creator." What's the world teach?
You came from evolution.
You are the product of a rock.
That's what it says. Yes.
The earth dissolved,
created eventually the materials out of
which law life evolved spontaneously.
So, you come from a rock.
I believe that I come from a rock, but
the rock of ages.
And the other sheep I have, which are
not of this fold, them also must I
bring, and they shall hear my voice, and
there shall be one fold and one
shepherd. You cannot have a divided
truth. Either there's truth
or there is division.
And you cannot have unity in falsehood.
Yes or no?
No. You either have unity in truth or
there is no unity. There is only a
presumptive unity that at the first
trouble will fall apart as though it had
never existed. Either it is based on
truth or it's based on nothing. Here is
the patience of the saints. Here are
they that keep the commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus. Revelation
14:12.
Do you know what?
Fascinating sentence there. The faith of
Jesus.
Wow.
The Bible has very high standards.
Do you know that it's not enough to have
faith in Jesus?
It's
not enough.
You need the faith
of Jesus.
In the greatest adversary,
Jesus trusted in the merits of his
father. Yes or no?
Yes.
No matter what happens to you, you need
to trust like he trusted. That's the
standard.
Well, God adds his merit because we are
weak, and we cannot do these things. But
that's the standard. That's something to
aim for. Wow, I wish I had the faith of
Jesus.
That I would be willing to go to the
cross because I knew that
he would resurrect me.
And I would be his eternally.
I could die no matter what happened.
Jesus had that faith. We need that kind
of faith. How many people have that kind
of faith still today? The standards in
the Bible are high.
And they're high with a reason.
And the message goes out to the world
that Jesus Christ is Lord.
And we are right here.
And the heavens departed as a scroll
when it is rolled together, and every
mountain and island were removed out of
their places. We've gone through all the
seals.
We're right between the sixth and the
seventh seal.
The next thing that happens when that
last seal is opened, then the testament
of God is opened, and the kingdom
becomes the Lord's.
That means Jesus takes over on this
planet.
And he's coming again. We've been
through history. We are the last people,
the last ones
in this great message.
And the kings of the earth and the great
men and the rich men and the chief
captains and the mighty men and every
bondsman and every freedman hid
themselves in dens and rocks of the
mountains.
And said to the mountains and rocks,
"Fall on us and hide us from the face of
him that sitteth on the throne and from
the wrath of the lamb, for the great day
of his wrath is come, and who shall be
able to stand?" That's the next thing
that's going to happen. And by the way,
please look that the people hide
themselves.
There's no great joy by the great
multitudes are. When judgment comes, you
have to stand.
There's no such thing as everyone will
be saved. You have to make a decision
here.
And then follows chapter 7,
which is parenthetical and tells us who
will be able to stand. And it says,
"Only the sealed will be able to stand."
And when he had opened the seventh seal,
there was silence in heaven about the
space of half an hour.
Well, if you work that into prophetic
time, it's about a week
or exactly a week.
So, the question is, what is the silence
about? I believe heaven is empty
because Christ and all his angels
are down here to receive the redeemed.
Christ is coming again with power and
glory. And either we are rooted in him
or we are not. That is the choice that
we have.
And I would suggest that we accept the
fact that Jesus is in control.
Jesus has given us a vision of the great
throne room where he is seated
in the throne of power.
And he is the one who has the authority
to open the seals
to receive a kingdom. And we can be part
of it or we can reject it.
My prayer is that we will all accept
salvation in him because he is the only
name whereby we can be saved. Amen.
>> Mhm.